well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages
coming up then we will see what's making
the headlines with the observer's chief
leader writer sonia soder
and the chief executive of conservative
home mark wallace welcome to both of you
staying right through until midnight as
well well coming up then let's see first
of all what's on the front pages
on the day an agreement was reached
between paris and westminster
over how to deal with migrant crossings
the metro describes a french warship
escorting an overcrowded dinghy onto
british shores
as gumbo diplomacy the times leads on
the line that migrant crossings hit a
new record today with the home secretary
pretty patel
under fire as huge numbers crossed the
channel in just one
day the daily mail also mentioning the
home secretary and her 54 million pound
agreement with france to stop
migrants crossing the channel well they
expressed leads on the same story
calling it a migrant crisis
as beach patrols by french police could
be doubled
according to the daily telegraph
ministers are encouraging bruce johnson
to broaden the exemptions which could be
given to people pinged by the nhs
kovadab to include public sector workers
and supermarket staff
the daily mirror reports that more than
a million children missed school last
week because they were
isolating financial times predicts
heightened tensions with the european
union
as the uk government outlines its
intention to redraft the post-brexit
northern ireland protocol whereas the
guardian claims president macron is
among world leaders who appear on the
leaked pegasus
project data and the star
mocking prince harry's plans to publish
a memoir
well let's bring in sonia soda and mark
wallace then
calm seas a beautiful weather not
surprising sonia
more migrants are arriving on a number
of newspaper front pages
um what's the government to do about
this
well i think it is really tricky but i
think it is important to put these
figures
into context so um it is true
that record numbers um have lost this
week
um but one of the reasons for that is
and i think it's really important to say
straight up nobody wants people to be
risking their lives
on a vet what is a very very dangerous
crossing
often on you know the sorts of dinghies
you can buy in kind of um
supermarkets or hardware stores so it's
not really a good outcome for anyone
these are very desperate people and
that's why they're taking
um these risks but i think it is
important to put this in the context
of what's happening in the asylum system
more generally
so it's important to say that the uk has
far fewer
asylum you know people arriving here
regular irregularly
making asylum applications in other
countries in europe for example far
fewer than in france or germany
our level of asylum applications is also
a lot lower than it was about 15 or 20
years ago
so this is a crisis in the sense of we
don't want very desperate people fleeing
conflict zones to be risking their life
to get across to britain
and one of the reasons that more people
are making the channel crossing is
because
other routes that might be safer for
them to get come to the uk
and claim asylum aren't haven't been so
open during the pandemic which is i
think why you're seeing more people risk
their lives
um but at the same time it's it's not a
crisis
in asylum numbers that pretty patel is
trying to sort of present it out so i
think it's very important to keep it in
context the real context
the real crisis in our asylum system is
the
massive delays which means that once
people come here and they claim asylum
they're waiting years to have that
application process that wastes a huge
amount of money in the uk and it wastes
asylum seekers time and also
the terrible conditions that we expect
people um fleeing conflict who
legally apply for for safe house for
asylum in the uk we have a moral
obligation
um to treat those applications fair
fairly under international law
and um some of them live in absolutely
terrible conditions they're subsisting
on about five pounds a day
some of them are actually kind of
incredibly skilled people who've come
from you know really
serious conflict zones like iraq syria
they're not allowed to work for years on
end
while they're waiting for their
applications to be processed so i think
that's a real crisis in the system and
where we should be focusing obviously we
don't want people
to be risking their lives crossing the
channel but i think the way to sort that
out
is to open up safer and more regular
routes for people who want to come and
claim asylum in the uk
yes you've listed a whole range of broad
issues um concerning
asylum seeking migration but back to
today
the metro amongst a number of newspapers
that talk about this
french warship that almost literally
escorted people onto the uk beaches
if we then go to the telegraph this idea
of paying france to deal with it
patel hands france an extra 53 million
pounds
to patrol the beaches as 700 migrants
arrive as the
telegraphs take on this story as well um
is it right to pay france to to tackle
this
should there be more agreement between
these two neighbours
mark well yes i think that is the right
approach and in venice it's been the
approach to a variety of different
agreements and treaties for
many years between the two countries it
makes sense to try and
uh patrol where these boats are
embarking from
but as well as of course being um a huge
risk for
the people on these posts this is also
an or a serious organized crime problem
this is
what we're seeing here is the regular um
activity of organized crime groups and
people traffickers
risking the lives of other people for
large profit while
breaking the law at the same time under
everybody's noses and that's that's
another reason why it matters
now i agree with sonia about the fact
that the process
needs to speed up i agree with her that
there are some
cruel ironies frankly in how it
malfunctions currently
for example it doesn't make sense to
have people who are
trained engineers or doctors or all
sorts of people who
while they're waiting for their
application to be processed in the
asylum system
and are forbidden from putting their
skills to use are forbidden from working
contributing to this country
while they go through that process but
none of that is a reason why this should
not be stopped it is a very serious
issue i don't agree that
pretty patel's somehow over hyping it i
think i i think it does matter and
of course a major reason why this
country has fewer asylum applications
um than various other countries in
europe and and other regions of the
regions of the world is we are an island
at the western end of the land mass of
europe
and a lot of people seeing those
photographs and watching that footage
that your colleagues
um have shown on sky today and we'll be
watching that thinking
this is patently absurd you have a
natural border around most of this
country and
it ought to be policeable yes i mean
maybe we can get some of those pictures
you talked about i mean extraordinary
scenes really are people leaping from
these boats
uh freedom for them many of them are
english speakers those that came today
the ones we managed to speak to seem to
seem to come from eritrea
iran as well was listed um the daily
express though
not happy about this deal with the
french migrant crisis patel pays french
54 million to do their job
similar for the daily mail as well some
outrage there
now pretty channels 54 million pounds to
france as a french warship escorts
migrants into uk waters
um but as you said this is just one part
of a
of a massive issue uh is it not sonya um
the uh immigration bill what will it do
uh pretty patel in front of the home
affairs select
committee tomorrow what would she say
what are you what are you expecting to
hear from the government on this
well i think there are massive problems
with the um asylum bill first of all it
doesn't address some of the real
problems in the system that i've talked
about so um ensuring that there are safe
ways for people to come to the uk who
are genuinely
fleeing terrible um conflict zones
fleeing despots human rights abuses so
it doesn't speed up the system it
doesn't fit any of that stuff
but what it does do is it does two
things that i think are
more about dog whistling to the public
and exaggerating the problem than
actually coming up with genuine
solutions
so it it it's going to try and make it a
crime
uh to come to the uk to um seek asylum
um to arrive irregularly
which actually i think there are massive
questions about whether that's
even legal under international law and
secondly um
it sort of includes legal provisions for
people who come here to seek asylum to
be deported
to a third country and to have their
applications processed
to wait while their applications are
being processed in the third country
again that is just kind of needless dog
whistling and signaling to
um the public from the government
because there aren't any third countries
that we've got these agreements with
there are very unlikely to be third
countries who
um will sort of enter into these
agreements with us and the concern is
actually that the sorts of countries
that might are countries where human
rights abuses arrive and you only need
to look at
what's happened with australia and the
territory of australia now
where um asylum seekers
were have terrible terrible human rights
abuses so this bill
does not address it it doesn't properly
address the source of the organized
crime as mark said it doesn't address
problems
in the asylum system it's acting as a
dog whistle to the british public
you know the government trying to say
we're cracking down here in ways that
actually i think go against both
britain's moral obligation to genuine
asylum seekers
and against international law
potentially yeah sorry to cut you off
mark i'm going to move on i know you've
already said that that bill is
is there to tackle the serious organized
crime problem
part of this so uh if you don't mind i'm
going to move on to covid
of which there is still a plenty in the
papers uh including the daily telegraph
uh the prime minister urged to expand
covert app exemptions we heard today
that there won't be some ground list
you'll have to apply um you know the
pandemic as it's now known
you know what's going to happen to the
uk with the pandemic
well i i think a big part of this
question is do people
want the app and and the the pinging as
it were
to do what it was originally meant to do
or is there meant to be
is there a kind of unspoken upper
threshold and part of the difficulty
we've seen with some confusion of the
line between
different ministers and downing street
today about exactly what being pinged
via the app actually means
stems from that the fact is that if you
see
ministers who are charged with uh
responsibility for business people who
are trying to get businesses
uh open keep them afloat to help get get
the economy going
they're out giving advice um one at one
moment talking about
how businesses can deal with this as an
advisory question through the app
the next moment the the line comes out
from downing students that actually know
you or do you
you you must isolate if you get if you
get that notification
part of this difficulty is you can't
have both of those things being true at
once otherwise
you know both ends are pulling against
the middle and nobody knows what on
earth they're doing you end up with the
worst of both worlds yeah i mean i
suppose people know they are supposed to
because the rules change in august don't
they so it's it's it's as you were
uh but paul scully's you said the small
business minister uh saying it's up to
individuals and employers whether to
self-isolate
after being alerted by the app to which
danny street said no no no
um and you look at the daily mirror um i
guess thank goodness
everyone's heading into uh summer
holidays in terms of education one
million kids off school
last week sonia yeah well i think you
know as you were just saying anna the
public health messaging has been so
confusing it's so important that it's
clear and there are clear instructions
on what to do and there have been real
problems with that in the last 24 hours
and then this story on the front of the
mirror is one million kids were off
school
last week i actually know several
friends with kids at primary school
and a few of them were having to
self-isolate miss the last week before
summer
which is really heartbreaking especially
for children who are in year six you
know they're saying goodbye to friends
and teachers
and it's just a real problem because
with infection rates this high
it is inevitable that um you know that
kids are going to be asked to
self-isolate so
i think the when we take a step back the
big question about this about the
pandemic
about kids being off school um and
really you know this is a big question
going to the autumn is
are we even though we're all more
vaccinated are we doing the right thing
by letting the virus spread
so fast because i personally think we
need to be
prioritizing having kids in school and
if we all need to do a little bit
less to keep infection rates lower so
fewer children
miss school in the last six weeks that
is that to me is a very very important
thing to do
yeah i mean you're sort of arguing the
pandemic distracts from the broader
question
which is allowing uh opening uh
during rising cases so that is a
question that the government
has to accept at some point is a gamble
we will see what happens
and plenty more still to come though in
our program including brexit not
featured too much on the program lately
but a new diplomatic row is brewing
more on that in just a moment
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now sonia soda and
mark wallace welcome back to both of you
and cast your mind back to sausage wars
mark are we back there again in the ft
well i think this is some um attempt uh
to try and find some kind of sausage
truce at least with the idea that
they go to the government exploring
different ways um
to try to uh free up effectively the
travel of
you know if you're talking about
sausages bangers from birmingham to
belfast
despite the disruption and more while
looking for way because of the
disruption we've seen due to the
protocol
so what what is the what is the plan uh
because the financial times suggesting
that
this will set the uk on a collision
course with brussels
again uh the uk will put itself on a
collision course
with the eu by unveiling new demands
that will radically overhaul
post-brexit trading arrangements between
britain and northern ireland
um doesn't sound like it'll go down well
from this article sonia
it doesn't and that we've been here
before the uk's already and david frost
have already issued
threats that they would break the
protocol um and just sort of
you know unilaterally if the eu doesn't
um sort of concede to british demands
i think the problem is here we've got to
take a step back the uk
signed this agreement they signed we
signed this protocol
because of the type of brexit that we
wanted and it was a compromise that we
reach with the eu big compromises were
reached were made on both sides
the eu made some very significant
compromises including
um the u giving the power to uk to
police its external border the uk made
compromises from
its starting point and now britain just
seems to think well now that we've got
the deal
we can rip it up and start again and
hold the eu
as a hostage of fortune that really
isn't the way that these trades into big
international trade deals um
work and the issue is we've got to work
with the eu allies and partners as well
as a
story we were just discussing on my
illegal migration
and asylum on france um shows so i
really do think this is a misjudgment
and a massive misstep by david frost
here who doesn't seem to get the
principles of international negotiation
with close allies and trading partners
and for the uk just to be like well if
you don't do what we want
we're just going to rip it up given the
legacy mark is gesticulating wildly with
his face so 20 20 seconds mark if you
don't mind
so the tradition known as shaking my
head the you know
two key questions firstly we signed this
agreement as did the eu
and does it or does it not say within it
that it can be
disapplied if it causes and if it causes
excessive disruption which i i think
it's david foster right to argue that it
is to do parts of the economy of
northern ireland
secondly what exact compromise did the
eu make
equivalent to the united kingdom um
when we're now told not not you know
sacrificing the right to fully and
freely trade with part of its own
country okay
um i think we're gonna have to go on
very quickly then
go on then very very well it's a big
compromise for the eu to allow another
a non-member state to police's external
border it's external
our joint border is that that's our
border isn't it the northern irish
border with ireland is our about half of
ours
tax in the irish sea it was allowing the
uk
i mean part of the protocol is that the
uk police say the uk is not a member
state of the eu anymore that is a big
compromise from the eu